at this point you should know what
monetization method you want to use and
how you'll implement it you might also
have a plan B in the back of your head
in case that first one doesn't work out
and you should also have a plan for
tracking and measuring the success of
your model keep in mind you can apply
the user segment you created a previous
unit to any of these reports this will
help you get insights per group which is
much more accurate as Yogi Berra said
you can observe a lot just by watching
in our world keep watching your users in
the next lesson you'll learn how to
iterate on your monetization model
changing your approach when you're not
making the amount of money that you need
to